bonjour bonjour V vous faites partie du
juré de l'émission maison la plus
originale tout à fait est-ce que vous
pouvez m'en dire un peu plus sur cette
fameuse émission bien sûr alors c'est
une émission qui va rentrer dans sa 3è
saison au cours de laquelle nous partons
à la découverte des maisons les plus
originales en compagnie d'une
décoratrice et d'un scénographe maison
plus originale qu'est-ce qu'on entend
par là c'est une maison qui ne ressemble
pas aux autres alors il peut s'agir
d'une maison extrêmement ancienne il
peut s'agir d'usine réhabilitée il peut
s'agir d'une maison dont la décoration
ne ressemble à euh aucune autre une
maison d'artiste par exemple et puis
enfin il peut s'agir d'une maison qui ne
ressemble aucune autre parce qu'elle est
extrêmement innovante et ce qui nous a
amené ce qui nous a amené effectivement
à à visiter beaucoup de maisons
extrêmement modernes et notamment des
maisons passives ou à énergie positive
très bien ben ça tombe très bien ça
faire parce que des maisons extrêmement
innovantes ça ne manque pas sur ce site
de Solar Décathlon ça vous dirait de
visiter quelques maisons de plus près
mais écoutez bien sûr moi les maisons
c'est une de mes passions vous savez je
suis fils d'architecte petit fils
d'architecte exactement et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que M6 m'a proposé de
faire partie de ce de ce jury et je suis
extrêmement intéressé éidemement à
savoir si c'est une maison qui est belle
pas belle qui me plaît ou pas et cetera
mais surtout repérer je suis très
intéressé par le fait de repérer des
innovations qui peut-être demain vont
nous servir avoir des maisons plus
économes plus agréables à habiter voilà
c'est ce qu'on devrait trouver ici parce
que nous avons les les habitats du futur
ben écoutez c'est alors on va aller
regarder comment ça marche de
l'intérieur ve plisir et on commence par
la maison italienne qui est présentée
par des architectes et des ingénieurs
qui viennent de Rome voilà on dit un mot
alorsamo je vous
suis bon il y a quelqu'un voilà Mac nous
voici dans une maison qui vient de Rome
conçue à Rome et on va regarder en quoi
cette maison est originale innovante au
niveau de l'énergie et de plein de
choses comme ça déjà vous pouvez voir
là-haut ces deux grandes ê de toi tout à
fait voilà qui ont pour mission de
donner une lumière
permanente à la maison alors je devine
en plus qu'elles sont orienté au nord
comme nos ateliers d'artistes voilà et
pas au sud de manière à faire rentrer la
lumière mais pas la chaleur exactement
parce que vous savez comme moi caroM il
fait une chaleur de bête très chaud
voilà et froid un peu l'hiver donc cette
maison est conçue en fonction de ce
problème là donc vous avez un patio au
nord pour prendre le frais l'été et un
paau que nous verrons plus tard au sud
pour avoir un peu de chaleur l'hiver
donc c'est une maison qui est à la fois
extrêmement moderne dans sa conception
mais qui s'appuie sur les usages des
habitants et qui tient vraiment compte
des conditions locales notamment une
forte chaleur l'été c'est bien ça voilà
qui tient compte des conditions
climatiques et aussi du fait que
l'Italie est un pays sujet au trbl
terire donc les murs peuvent bouger très
légèrement et ça ne pose aucun problème
ah c'est une construction antissismique
voilà c'est ce que je cherchais comme
mot très bien je vais te le refaire non
c'est pas grave j'ume très bien on voilà
donc nous avons Barbara qui est là qui
nous accueille dans cette maison et qui
va vous en dire beaucoup plus que moi
voilà ciao Barbara ciao ça va alors moi
j'ai déjà remarqué quelque chose d'assez
inhabituel pour une maison neuve ce sont
les murs on voit très bien dans
l'encadrement des fenêtres qui sont très
épais pourquoi et pourquoi nous son lieu
la tradition et rain d'avoir un mur très
lourde qui permett d'avoir un
absorbiteur des chaleur et et qui permet
d'avoir un température constante pendant
tout le jour pendant tout l'année à
l'intérieur de la maison en français
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'inertie
thermique c'est direouinertie thermique
une maison qui est capable de garder
toute la journée la fraîcheur de la nuit
et de pas se réchauffer trop vite c'est
ça oui et c'est une chose très
importante pour nous pour l'Italie et
pour Rome particul surtout pour le sud
ouais surtout pour le les sou parce que
c'est un tradition Méditerranée et qui
permett de combattre les la chaleur de
l'été de façon naturelle voilà alors je
crois que vous avez eu tous ensemble les
architectes les ingénieurs italiensen
une idée incroyablement originale mon
cher Mac ça m'intéresse voilà j'espère
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ces murs ouais
nous avons pensé à un système
contemporaine donc nous avons à
l'intérieur un un une structure portante
en bois qui permet d'avoir une structure
flexible donc
antisismique mais aussi pour pour avoir
l'inertie thermique nous avons un
système de tubes d'aluminium qui sont
transportés vid ici et nous l'avons
rempli avec la sable et d'autres
matériaux lourdes qui permettent donc
d'avoir des mures qui absorbent la
chaleur pendant les jours les plus
chaudes et de le relacer pendant la nuit
quand nous pouvons ouvrir la le fenêtre
et la fenêtre des là haut la grande là
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure et faire faire
sortir la l' chaud l'air chaud ouais
pendant la nuit parce que c'est le sable
qui a cette propriété là ou ça pourrait
être n'importe quelle autre matère sable
son tous les matériaux qui permettent de
absorbir la chaleur ce n'est pas comme
une insolation c'est quelque chose de
plus ça permet donc de rafraîchir ou de
réchauffer la maison à volonté sans
recourir à des systèmes modernes de
climatisation avec réchauffement ou
refroidissement d'air donc avec une
dépense d'énergie minimale bah quasi nul
même ouais parce que le le système
passif vient dans l'Antiquité et dans
l'Antiquité nous n'avons pas des
systèmes actifs il y a pas de
climatiseur il y a pas de chauffage dans
l'Antiquité et c'est ce qu'on essaie de
reproduire ici mais les maisons fonction
fonctionn très bien ouais fonction ou et
donc Jul César habitait une maison
extrêmement confortable alors même qu'il
connaissait pas la climatisation voilà
voir ouais donc nous avons fait un
projet qui tient ensemble la tradition
mais aussi les futurs donc nous avons
des systèmes actifs que nous pouvons
voir i alors justement voilà il y a une
autre partie de la maison qui est très
importante comment vous l'appelez cette
partie la LOD Sud la logia Sud ouis
d'accord ah c'est le côté du soleil donc
là c'est c'est là j'imagine qu'on va
trouver des panneaux solaires c'est bien
ça ouais sont tous les systèmes actifs
de notre maison donc nous avons des
panneaux solaires
qui de couvrir inrement le l'espace à
l'extérieur parce que il fonctionne
comme un persiencord donc nous pouvons
dérouler les panneaux photovoltaïques
c'est les panneaux photovoltaïques
mobiles alors ça Véronique par
d'originalité c'est très original je
n'avais encore jamais vu ça ah vous
faites plaisir ça peut servir de
persienne tu peux les repouser sur tu
peux de exactement tu peux les repouser
sur le toi si tu veux que ta logia soit
en plein soleil et tu la tires comme un
store si tu veux que tà soit à l'ombre
c'est bien ça d'accord les meubles
intérieurs extérieurs sont des meubles
de récupération oui et sont fait par les
étudiants donc par nous et par moi et
parce que pour nous euh notre
philosophie c'est que tous les les
objets peuvent être recyclés donc ouais
donc nous avons pas des déchets nous
avons des ressources pour t les chos
d'accord déchets ressource ouais pour t
les choses pour le pour l'alimentation
parce que nous avons des jardins
urbaines voilà il y a aussi des
plantations il y a une vigne je crois
même non ouais ouais ok très
impressionnant merci Barbara bra merci
beaucoup et puis nous on va aller voir
une autre maison mais avec plaisir jeis
vous suis vonique complètement
différente cette fois-ci j'ai hâte de
voir suivez-moi je vous
suis alors Mac nous voici devant une
autre maison oui c'est une maison
germano-américaine et qu'est-ce qu'elle
spécial elle spécial qu'elle est en
textile imaginez-vous ah bon et pourquoi
pourquoi je ne sais pas on va all poser
quelques questions oui voilà de quoi il
retourne bonjour bonjour Mac enchanté
bonjour Hélène Véronique bonjour à notre
maison merci à maison on incroyable
alors c'est très beau parce que on voit
effectivement ce textile souple et tout
est à l'intérieur on est comme dans un
œuf pourquoi avoir choisi de faire une
maison avec du textile comme enveloppe
extérieure P c'est une exploration de la
matérial de textile nous avons une
département de textile à rad Island
School of Design qui était une membre de
notre équipe et pour nous nous nous
voulons développer une système de
construction qui est différent de comme
des autres maisons qui semble une boîte
pour nous c'est la oui ben oui c'est
vrai que les maisons habituelles
effectivement ça ressemble toujours à
des boîtes à
chaussures
on les cour très agréable et le choix de
la couleur blanche c'est pour plus de
lumière oui oui donc ici le textile et
pour faire des réflexions de lumière
oki moi quand on parle maison textile je
pense tout de suite à la tente du
camping et à la chaleur et à la chaleur
alors comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
avoir une maison dont le mur est en
textile mais qui soit pas extrêmement
chaude donc nous avons 30 cm
d'inallation aussi nous nous avons 30 cm
d'épaisseur de mur oui
entreation et aussi une membrane de
vapeur et aussi cette textile ici aussi
nous avons une système de climatisation
ici et de chauffage qui était comme une
maison passive qui utilise moins
d'énergie comme des autres maisons en
France et aux États-Unis est-ce que
c'est une maison qui est faite pour le
centre des villes non euh c'est ça c'est
euh notre maison est désignée pour la
campagne mais on peut util d' d'abord la
campagne oui mais on peut utilise cette
système dans tout toutes les S terrain t
les climat bon d'accord en ce cas
Véronique ça fait une maison regardez
qui est extrêmementumineuse c'est très
agréable et le fait de pas avir d'angle
droit je trouve que c'est extrêmement
apaisant moi je remarque quelque chose
de très joli C espèce de textile brodé
là qu'est-ce que c'est ça c'est de la
décoration pure c'est une décoration
cétait fait comme des élèves de
département de textile à rode Island
School of Design avec le marc stall qui
est à New York ok très bien c'est très
Jol é Hélène merci beaucoup oui et on
aperçoit aussi là-bas je crois c'est
quoi ces tub là oui cha c'est les une
panelle solaire thermique pour faire
l'eau chaude pour notre maison et aussi
nous avons une système de photovoltaïque
sur sur le toit incorporé dans le
textile exactement ça merci Hélène merci
et bravo oui et bon journée au revoir
merci allez allons-nous
en cette terrasse
hop
voilà
alors est-ce que vous avez eu votre
content
d'originalité alors oui Véronique tout à
fait on a vu deux maisons et d'autres
extrêmement originales et moi je dis
bravo évidemment il y a une grosse
différence mais oui il a une grosse
différence entre ces maisons et cell que
nous visitons dans notre émission la
maison la plus originale quelle est
cette différence alors cette différence
c'est que ce sont dans le casadre de
notre émission de vraies maisons avec de
vrais propriétaires et pas un petit peu
ici des exercices de style des
démonstrateurs alors j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de pouvoir visiter avec de vrais
gens de vrais propriétaires de vrais
architectes qui vivent à l'intérieur des
maisons aussi originales que cellees-ci
mais je repars pour une nouvelle saison
donc j'espère que je vais voir aussi
impressionnant que ça bon bah l'appel
est lancé mais exactement j'espère que
les propriétaires seront nombreux à
répondre à notre appel alors à vos idées
architecte et propriétaire de maison on
peut on peut dire ça ben écoutez merci
de faire découv ces maison magnifique
beau cadre versaillais c'est pas mal
très beau à bientôt Mac merci Véronique
vous à
bientôt